- Good morning!
I just woke up.
It's the day before the big Apple event.
I'm so excited!
But one of the most difficult things,
especially for a girl,
is what do you pack?
I mean, for such a
prestigious, and incredible,
and exciting event, I really had to put
some thought into it.
And I didn't want to
leave anything behind,
just in case I needed it.
So I'm gonna bring it all.
(grunting)
That should be big enough.
Do you think this is big enough?
I don't think it is either.
It's like when you go on a trip
and your friends say, "Hey, pack me
"in your suitcase."
I'm gonna do that for my friends.
Not an officially licensed
Apple product, but, cute!
This is essentially the celebration
of the 10th anniversary of this original
iPhone that changed everything.
We'll pack him!
This is the iPod.
This changed music as we know it.
I'll pack it!
I'm sure some of my old
iPhones wouldn't want
to sit at home. They want to come with me.
I'll pack them!
This was one of my favorite iPods.
I remember doing an
unboxing of this years ago,
sitting on my floor at my old place.
I'll pack it!
This is one of the red
iPod touches, oh, baby!
You're coming with us!
Don't worry!
No iPod or phone left behind.
What am I gonna wear?
This will look good with my emoji pants.
Let's do a little try-on.
Uh, I think I might think about getting
a different outfit.
I'll pack it!
(grunting)
No computer left behind.
This thing is so heavy.
Anytime I would need to take this
into the Apple store to get repaired.
or fixed, or upgraded.
In Los Angeles, there's this place called
the Third Street Promenade.
If you guys are not familiar with it,
it's basically a big,
long stretch of shops
on one street.
It's all closed off for pedestrians,
so you can't drive up.
So what you have to do is park really far
away from the Apple store
and carry your items.
And this thing is so heavy!
I've carried it from the parking garage,
down many flights of steps, all the way
to the Apple Store, and then back again.
But we'll pack it!
Usually, when packing, the best advice is
to pack the largest things first.
I didn't (grunting)
adhere to my own advice.
OK, I think I should probably
rearrange my small items.
So obviously, I'm not
gonna be able to use my
Mac Pro tower without a monitor.
That's dusty!
It's been in storage.
But what if I make a friend and they say,
"Justine, do you have an extra computer
"that I can use?"
And I'm gonna say, "Yes, I do, friend."
Squeeze in here.
I might need another suitcase.
At least I could put
the keyboard in there.
So I'm basically pulling
these all out of storage.
If you're saying, "Justine, why don't
"you sell your things?"
No, this is my collection.
These are my items.
This is my pride, my joy.
Most people have children,
I have this and a dog.
What if I need a CD or a DVD?
Well, of course, I can bring this.
Perhaps an iPad.
This is the original MacBook Air.
Look at this!
You're coming with me!
So this wasn't the iPad Air, but this was
the first super thin MacBook.
Yeah, I'll pack you!
This was my first MacBook
that I ever bought.
This is what I started
my YouTube channel on, basically.
This thing right here.
We've been through some things together.
I'll pack it!
Oh, I'll pack it!
What else do I need?
Maybe a brush because I look like a mess.
I just woke up and I'm like,
"I gotta pack, for real.
"I gotta make this video."
What else should I pack?
What else do I need?
So before the Apple Watch,
was the Apple Watch.
Now this is such an awesome watch.
I don't remember what year this is from.
So unfortunately, the
battery is dead on this.
But when it did work
before, the watch hands
used to go in the reverse direction
that normal watch hands would go.
Well thank you guys for watching
and thank you so much for all your support
in the comments.
I was reading through
all of them yesterday
when I was reading through my
little announcement video.
I was so excited!
I also had filmed that
video a few days ago
before I'd hit four million subscribers,
so I didn't get a chance
to actually thank you
in the video.
So thank you guys so much!
I can't believe it!
I've been on YouTube for so freaking long!
Today I feel like a lot
of you guys were like,
"Oh, four million.
"You just hit four million now?"
I did, I did.
But you know what?
I'm still here, I'm still making videos,
and I still actually really genuinely love
what I'm doing.
So thank you guys for
letting me entertain you
or letting me let you make fun
of me all the time.
Which is also fine.
Let's say hi to everybody.
Here, boost up.
This is my sweetie!
He just went to the groomer's
and he's looking so nice.
I gotta take Manny to his babysitter soon.
I wish I could bring
you to the Apple event.
I'm sure I could because
they would love you!
They would love my angel.
Anyway, thanks again
for four million subs.
Here's to another million or another four,
I don't even know.
Oh, thank you!
Are you proud of Mommy?
Oh, that's a kiss.
That's a wet mouth.
Well I will see you
guys at the Apple event.
Like I said before, make sure you guys
are following me on Twitter and Instagram
because I will be
updating there pretty much
as much as possible.
So with that being said,
now that I'm packed,
I have to go put all this stuff back
from where I got it and actually pack
and head to the airport.
Manny, I love you.
I love you so much.
Thanks for sitting here.
Let me tell you what is not flattering.
This outfit!
(upbeat music)